science magazine presents a special
issue each year on the scientific
breakthrough of the year in 2008 it's
reprogramming cells we decided to honor
cellular reprogramming this year because
this year the technology really came
into its own and scientists have started
to use it in the lab to perhaps better
understand human diseases in past years
people show that the technology was
possible in human cells but this year
they took things a step further and
we're getting closer now to actually
seeing the full potential that this
technology can offer to scientists well
all of us who are working with
reprogramming owe a debt to shinya
yamanaka whose real paradigm shifting
work occurred in 2006 we are using very
similar techniques to effect the
reprogramming now in human cells but
this is a major breakthrough because for
many years we've been seeking ways to
establish the cell culture models for
human disease and we finally achieved
that we should be able to generate
disease models having the same genetic
information with the patient's those
cells should be very useful in drug
screening and in toxicology most
directly cellular reprogramming builds
on two previous discoveries the first
was the discovery that you could keep
embryonic cells alive in the lab 10
years ago Jamie Thompson's groups
delivered to us as scientists human
embryonic stem cells and those are the
very primitive cells the master cells of
the human organism that come from the
earliest stages of human development the
blastocyst those cells are special
because they can then in the lab in
theory become any kind of cell in the
body they can become heart cells they
can become brain cells they can become
blood cells that technology was very
exciting for scientists but also brought
a lot of ethical questions with it
because it required the destruction of
human embryos to make the cells in the
first place and political debates and
political rules limited some of the work
that scientists were able to do with
those cells those embryonic stem cells
however are generic they're in most
instances essentially normal cells from
normal individuals so that doesn't give
us the opportunity to study disease the
second discovery happened two years ago
when scientists from Japan realized or
discovered that they could take just for
genes and by inserting four genes into
the tail cells taken from mice they
could get those tail cells to behave as
though they were in trionic cells as
though they looked and acted just like
embryonic stem cells that were taken
from mouse embryos this raised great
hopes among scientists that you could
get embryonic-like cells in the lab dish
without having to deal with actually
using embryos and all the legal and
ethical questions that surrounded that
work they called these cells the
Japanese scientist named d cells induced
pluripotent stem cells or IPS cells
based on the success of cloning in rocks
and in mammals we thought that we should
be able to induce 3d potency in somatic
cells by introducing some specific
factors and we hypothesized that if we
induce through potency maintenance
factor into somatic cells those factors
might be able to induce three potency in
somatic cells based on that hypothesis
we try to identify many factors that are
involved in the maintenance of potency
in Mouse ES cells and we identified 24
such factors and out of those 24 factors
we found that the combination of four
factors can actually induce three
potency in mouse fibroblasts very
luckily it turned out that the exactly
the same four factors can induce human
IPS
now in some instances one can derive
embryonic stem cells from embryos that
are going through pre-implantation
genetic diagnosis that is couples who
know they carry disease genes might test
their embryos so as to prevent the
disease and a child so that has given us
models embryonic stem cell models of
certain rare genetic conditions like
fragile x syndrome or fanconi anemia but
the induced pluripotent stem cells this
new strategy of factor based
reprogramming allows us to create a cell
model for any person on earth and that
means all of the many thousands of
diseases that are represented in the
human race scientists from several
groups have managed this with at least
10 different diseases including Down
syndrome Huntington's disease
Parkinson's disease ALS amyotrophic
lateral sclerosis and several others
another aspect of the breakthrough is
that this year scientists figured out
that they could use cellular
reprogramming to turn one kind of adult
cell directly into another kind of fully
mature cell that goes against all sorts
of biological rules that people had
thought usually the course of
development is a one-way street you
cells choose their path and they don't
ever once they've gone down one path
they can't just jump over to another
path and become a different kind of cell
this year scientists figured out in live
mice that they could insert genes into
one kind of cell in the pancreas and
turn it directly into another kind of
cell the cell that happens to produce
insulin is missing in diabetes this
suggests that perhaps the technology
could be used not only to bring cells
way back to the beginning to their
embryonic state but also you could take
say a skin cell and turn it directly
into the cell of interest that would
help you study or treat a disease
we know very little about how this works
how the three or four factors can induce
reporting see in somatic cells so I
think to understand those mechanisms is
one of the most important future goals
in this field what we do know is that
the reprogramming factors themselves are
these master regulators they're in most
instances transcription factors those
are proteins that bind to DNA and alter
the expression of genes in some cases
they'll turn genes on in other cases
they'll turn genes off but what they
initiate is this global ramada fication
of the state of the cell before the
promise of cellular reprogramming
reprogram cells really becomes a reality
scientists need to understand a lot more
about what's actually happening inside
these cells they know that the process
works they've been able to figure out
several alternative techniques to make
it work and they're using those
techniques to better understand what's
going on they have a few guesses about
what these jeans these inserted genes
actually do to the cell to make it
forget the developmental path at once
took and go back to its undifferentiated
state to the IPS cell state but they
need to do some more work to really
figure out what's happening and to
really understand whether these cells
are truly the equivalent to the
embryonic stem cells that people
originally had so much hope for and that
people still have hope for using one of
the questions that's often asked is
whether induced pluripotent stem cells
will replace the need for embryonic stem
cells I believe very strongly that they
will not my laboratory continues to
study embryonic stem cells side by side
with these new induced pluripotent stem
cells in fact the embryonic stem cells
remain the gold standard after many
years of studying embryonic stem cells
we have some comfort with their
performance
and we don't we don't know yet whether
the induced pluripotent stem cells are
in fact identical there have many
functional similarities and for the last
year we've spent a lot of effort trying
to convince everyone how similar they
are to the embryonic stem cells but over
the next many months we're going to see
a flurry of papers that will report
critical differences between the IPS
cells and the ES cells and we don't yet
know how relevant those differences are
going to be to our ability to make use
of them in research let alone in therapy
so no I think in the long run we're
going to see continued investigation of
embryonic stem cells side by side with
the new induced pluripotent stem cells
all I can say is we are doing we and
many other researchers are doing our
best to bring this technology to
patients as quick as possible
science is published by Triple A as the
science society